se aclara la pista alemana en el caso de
madeleine mccann 15 años después de la
desaparición de la niña británica de
tres años la fiscalía portuguesa anunció
que pidió la imputación de un sospechoso
alemán y aunque su identidad no fue
revelada por las autoridades portuguesas
alemania dijo que se trataba de cristian
brückner un hombre de 45 años
actualmente detenido en este país por un
caso de violación kate y gerry mccann
padres de madeline acogieron el anuncio
y esperan que este último acontecimiento
les ayude a encontrar a su hija aunque
la posibilidad sea escasa no hemos
perdido la esperanza de que madeleine
siga viva y de que nos podamos reunir
con ella la tragedia de los mccann tuvo
lugar el 3 de mayo de 2007 durante unas
vacaciones familiares en el sur de
portugal ese día los padres dejaron en
el apartamento a madeline dormida junto
con sus dos hermanos gemelos menores que
ella y salieron a cenar con amigos a un
restaurante a menos a metros de
distancia alrededor de las diez de la
noche constataron que la niña había
desaparecido
inicialmente la policía portuguesa
sospechó de ellos pero fueron excluidos
de la investigación un año más tarde 12
años después en junio de 2020 las
policías británica portuguesa y alemana
anunciaron tener una pista sólida la de
cristian brückner que había recibido de
manera regular en el sur de portugal de
1995 a 2007 un hombre con un largo
historial delictivo y que ella fue
condenado por tráfico de drogas
falsificación o robo pero también por
varios casos de pedofilia y por la
violación de una mujer de 70 años